the Joe Rogan experience another one of
my favorite papers he did it was fat
body that's what yeah yeah fat body
building fat body building um so it
turns out Peter has a friend in Richard
Baldwin and you should pull Richard
Baldwin up Richard Baldwin is a real
professional bodybuilder he was like
what was it mr. Olympia in 1978 or
something right and he's also a history
professor so dudes jacked even 70
something he's jacked and so he said we
could use his identity to our papers
yeah that's him is in the 70s yeah I'm
that him now he's got a woman a black
t-shirt or it's like he's 71 years old
and it's just the upper yeah the one the
one where he's doing the most muscular
pose right there BAM he's still like
that and Jesus Christ so he let us use
his identity that that's him older he's
still jacked he's 65 there he's in he's
fit so we were like we got a right
bodybuilding theme papers because we
have a bodybuilder mm-hm and so we
claimed that his his there is the
Blackwell ated images down there as
where as in the black t-shirt I actually
photoshopped a copy of that that
specific image you put fat bodybuilder
on the t-shirt I used to have that
picture that's him like when he was
letting us use his identity so there
he's in a 70 I think he's like 71 there
that's insane yeah look at those arms
Wow and yeah so we wrote this paper fat
bodybuilding saying that bodybuilders
are abnormally large fat people are
abnormally large muscle and fat are just
two types of tissue and it's only fat
phobic science that distinguishes their
worth and the fat phobic society that
says one means more than the other so we
even had lines like you know you have to
build a political there's some quote
it's not wasn't our line we quoted
somebody that says it takes time to
build a fat body it takes even more time
to build a politicized fat body so that
was the theme of the paper and so we
said that there should be in fact that
professional bodybuilding is a sport
needs to add another category there are
four categories for each of men and
women that we compete in apparent
something like bikini and I don't know
what their whatever they yes something
therefore and I don't remember what they
are but they need to add a fifth one in
for fat body building where people of
any body shape and size can come in and
it can't be competitive because that
would be fat shaming and so it has to be
just a political performative display
rooted in Judith Butler's politics of
parody oh my god which we got that idea
from reading an actual fat scholar maybe
the leading fat scholar Charlotte Cooper
and Charlotte Cooper is just like
totally not job activists in the UK but
they hate the Olympics as you might
imagine it's the maximally fat fat
phobic environment except sumo in the
Olympics is it I think it is but they
protested the two thousand and this is
in London so they protested the 2012
games Summer Games and what they did is
they held in a park like fatty limbic
says what they literally hold it they
literally call it that and it was like
them playing dizzy bat and like yelling
about and holding up protest signs about
how the Olympics sucks and so we're like
what in the hell is this and so then we
decided to write this fat bodybuilding
paper based off of the idea of politics
of parody of like making a joke out of
the thing so we're gonna make a joke at
a bodybuilding we said the competitors
can wear the fashion that's their word
not ours of their choice which is
clothing design for fat people
so it's really hard it's really hard to
Kurt to talk about to explain to
criticize the the fat study stuff
without like it's just so preposterous
how do you walk the line of like tipping
them off like because it seems like I
mean and some of your stuff is so loony
that I just thought like how do they not
know they're being [ __ ] with because
they're too serious about them they take
themselves too seriously so I'll give
you an example with that exact paper
right at the end Pete you know is a big
sci-fi guy so he's all into Star Trek so
we called the last section was fat body
building the final frontier for fat they
went berserk about this
they were like you cannot call it that
for two reasons you can't use the word
final because it would imply there is an
end to fat activism which can never end
oh my god and you can't use the word
frontier because it reminds you of
genocides the frontier like the frontier
the American West that said it evokes
imagery of the American West so you
can't say the final frontier
because front here the word Oh isn't God
it was I know frontier but that Star
Trek I know how are you doing that
they're so like I mean smelling their
own farts man only their own farts all
day long it's so so freakin bad that is
I can't I can't
I'm like as you're saying this I know
you're telling the truth but I I can't
imagine that this is this is literally
commonplace I mean it's it's so hard not
to laugh especially talk about health at
every size you know who made up health
at every size who linda bacon that's her
name she's not real
she's real it's like and it's like it's
just her name it just happened to be
crazy though what a great name it just
shows you that the world like when
Andrew Weiner kept scented his dick two
girls I know come on man this is too
on-the-nose Jesus when I was in grad
school actually we had to learn about so
there's this thing in probability theory
it's named after a mathematician whose
last name is wiener and so it's actually
called the Wiener measure and so we had
this Chinese teacher he was talking
about the Wiener measure and we're all
laughing and he had no idea why we were
laughing his English wasn't great oh
it's so awkward
[Applause]